LULU CHEN: My experience
was very heartwarming.
SPEAKER 1: Empowering.
CHRISTIAN LAWSON: Aesthetic.
ANDREA AYALA: Story-telling.
SPEAKER 2: Incredible.
SPEAKER 3: International
experiences are indescribable.
You just have to go.
[MUSIC, PIANO PLAYING]
CHRISTIAN LAWSON: Just
international experience
is a wonderful thing to have.
And the arts are really
what gets me about Germany,
just the musical
traditions, starting
from the Baroque
period moving onward.
I've been composing
for over a year now.
And I felt that that
was one way in which I
could express myself uniquely.
ANASTASIA VRACHNOS:
Princeton now
is providing an incredible
array of possibilities
for students to have
international experiences.
Learning Across Borders, or
LABs, as we've come to call it,
brings them together to share
their insights and learnings,
to glean a sense of what other
students' experiences have
been, but also to help students
who haven't yet gone abroad
get a sense of the possibilities
and what they might learn
and what the
challenges might be.
LULU CHEN: I went to
the Indian Institute
of Cerebral Palsy, which is
located in Kolkata, India.
People who read my blog get
a really real experience
of what it is to be there,
not just all the small
joys, but also parts that
might have been difficult
and that helped me grow.
ANDREA AYALA: I decided
to go to Argentina.
I wanted to work in
social entrepreneurship.
And it's growing.
So it was really exciting
to be there at a time
where people were thinking
more about social issues.
I loved the idea of
networking and just
meeting all these
really cool people
and hearing their stories.
CHRISTIAN LAWSON:
Munich was just
incredibly interesting to me.
I happened to meet people there
who weren't from Princeton.
I think that's really where
the interesting things started
to happen.
I ended up just
going out with them.
And there was so much beauty
around me at the time.
And it was just one way I could
express it, through the piano.
I plan on using it as a
way of reminding myself
that there's all this
international experience
to be had.
And I don't want to
necessarily lock myself
into just this one country.
LULU CHEN: I've been
having really good days,
like able to
communicate with people
who spoke English or able to
say a couple phrases in Bengali.
And then I had met someone
who was hearing impaired.
And suddenly, I didn't know
how to communicate with them.
Even though it's very simple
to be able to put together
signs, symbols,
pictures and words,
it actually makes
a huge difference,
because now she is
able to express herself
to a variety of
different people.
ANDREA AYALA: What's so
amazing about traveling
is that you get to
see that there's not
one way of doing things.
And speaking a foreign
language somehow
makes each interaction seem
more significant, because you're
really thinking about what
you're saying and really
listening to them.
That really allows
you to connect to people.
LUISA DUARTE: You will have
other obligations that will not
give you the opportunity to
experience the world the way
you can during college.
So this is the time to try.
And this is the time to
take on the adventure.